good morning it's so good to be in
person
as it is you all pick your spots there
i'm elizabeth warren the senior senator
from the commonwealth of massachusetts
i am here with my colleagues brendan
boyle from pennsylvania
and pramila jaya paul from washington
state
and we're here to talk about the wealth
tax it is time
for a wealth tax in america i want to
remind everybody what the wealth tax is
it is a tax on the uh
fortunes above 50 million dollars
in other words your first 50 million is
free and clear
about your 50 millionth and first dollar
you got to pay 2 cents
and 2 cents on every dollar after that
until you hit a billion
when you had a billion you got to pay a
few cents more
um this is a wealth tax
that has been needed for a long time
we need it to produce more revenue to
create more opportunity
in america but it is a wealth tax that
we particularly need
because of the changes in this country
under the pandemic
we have watched the wealth
of the billionaire class in america
um increase by more than a trillion
dollars
over the last year a two cent wealth tax
would just help level the playing field
a little bit and create the kind of
revenue
that would let us build back better as
joe biden says would let us make the
investments
in our children investments in
infrastructure
investments in a clean economy
investments in america's future
so i'm delighted to be here today to
roll this out and to take questions
but first we want to hear from
congressman boyle and let me put my mask
back on
congresswoman jayapal
thank you so much senator uh so grateful
for your tremendous leadership on this
for
quite some time now and to my colleague
in the house we're thrilled to be
working on this in partnership with the
senator
this is a moment where i think
structural inequality
and inequity has really been laid bare
during this pandemic and this economic
crisis
it is a moment where one in seven
families don't have enough to eat
more than eight million people have been
pushed into poverty
nearly one million new people every week
are filing unemployment claims
and that's on top of the more than 75
million who have lost their jobs
this historic loss of jobs has also also
led to a historic loss of health care
and all of this has happened as we've
surpassed 512 000 deaths
due to covet but as working families
have struggled and as their savings have
dried up and food banks have been
overwhelmed
as the senator said the rich have only
gotten richer
u.s billionaires have become 1.3
trillion dollars richer since covet
began that is a 44
jump in their wealth just since march
and it's not just a few billionaires
getting wealthier
there have been 46 new billionaires
created during this pandemic
now today the richest one percent owned
35 percent of the nation's wealth and
the richest
one-tenth of one percent that's 0.1
percent
own more than 18 percent of america's
wealth then just compare that
to the entire bottom half of americans
owning just 1.5 of wealth
so in the simplest terms there are the
richest 130 000 families in america
who hold nearly as much wealth as the
bottom 117 million families combined
now i wanted to spend a minute on black
and brown and indigenous families in the
racial wealth gap
because this is really critic critical
it's particularly staggering when you
look at racial inequality
as related to wealth white families have
an average
wealth that is more than 14 times as
much as black families
and eight times as much as latinx
families and in fact the 400
richest americans own more wealth than
all all black households
and a quarter of latino households
combined
that's happening as one in three black
and latinx families have zero or
negative wealth
and for asian americans a group that is
way too little studied
and there's way too little information
here in income and wealth distribution
inequality has gone from being one of
the most equal
to actually one of the most unequal
among major racial groups in the united
states
now this is no accident our history is
that much of the wealth of white
families
accumulated at the expense of black
brown and indigenous
families from legalized slavery to
redlining
and the extreme inequality and
concentration of wealth and racial
inequity is baked into our tax system
because
we only tax income and wages and not
wealth
that has been amassed through business
or equity or real estate
fine arts and then we pass it down
through inheritances
remaining free of taxes for the most
part the whole time so it's a wealth
inequality level that no
other leading country in the world has
seen
our legislation as the senator said
finally helps just
level the playing field and ensures that
the wealthiest begin to pay their fair
share
and it does so all the while investing
trillions of dollars into our
communities
you already heard what it does a two
percent annual tax on those who have a
net worth
between 50 and a billion dollar 50
million and a billion dollars and yeah
you pitch in a little bit more
if you've got more than a billion but if
you're like
99.95
of americans who have a net worth of
less than 50 million dollars
you pay nothing new not a penny this tax
only impacts a hundred thousand
households the top
zero point zero five percent
but still it would bring in three
trillion dollars over ten years
just imagine what we could do with three
trillion dollars
that's coveted relief it's healthcare
it's infrastructure education
a transition to renewable energy and
affordable housing
all the while reducing that racial
wealth gap
and that's why the majority of americans
support an ultra millionaire tax
poll after poll has found that voters
are with us on this
that it is time for the rich to pay
their fair share it's not just democrats
it's moderates it's independents and
even a plurality
of republicans so i'm looking forward to
working on this
in the house with my colleagues and to
bringing
finally a fairness and an equity to our
system
thank you and i yield now to the great
gentleman from the state of pennsylvania
mr boyle
thank you well thank you
i'm congressman brendan boyle as premila
mentioned from commonwealth of
pennsylvania also a member of the ways
and means committee
and vice chair of the committee on the
budget uh i want to thank senator warren
and my colleague in the house
representative jayapal it's great to be
i'm just very excited to be working with
them uh on this concept as some of you
know
who might cover tax issues i've been
working on and my staff and i working on
this concept for the last couple years
now
and really believe in working with this
to these two
outstanding legislators that the time is
right
what we're talking about here today is
bigger than just one piece of
legislation
it goes to the heart of the american
dream itself
i was raised in a household that
believed in the american dream
almost like it was our religion my
father came to america when he was 19
spent the next 50 years working blue
collar jobs
because he believed in the american
dream
and i tell you this the hyper
concentration of wealth
among the top tenth of one percent
is a mortal threat to the american dream
consider that in the last generation
while the share of the wealth owned by
the very top has tripled
the size of the great american middle
class has shrunk
and it has shrunk according to pew
considerably
this is the first generation mine is the
first generation in american history
that can say they have seen the decline
of the size of the american middle class
as elizabeth was was recently reminding
me when we were speaking
an american born around the same time as
my father
had a 90 percent chance to make more
than his parents did
while an american born around the same
time i was
has about a 50-50 chance that's not
consistent
with the american dream the
unprecedented spike in wealth
among a tiny sliver of the population
is stifling both opportunity and social
mobility
so the wealth tax is both a fair and
necessary step
to begin to address this existential
challenge
now let me address two criticisms i've
heard from the outset
first there are those who will say this
is socialism or
communism or god knows what else they'll
come up with
well they said the same exact thing
about franklin roosevelt's proposals
in the 1930s they were wrong then and
they were wrong now
franklin roosevelt wasn't a socialist he
saved capitalism
in the united states and this proposal
is offered
very much in that same spirit second
there are those who say i've even seen
as recently as this morning
but those who say that this tax is both
unprecedented
and unconstitutional the reality is this
concept is not new
and is perfectly legal in fact i
standing here will tell you
i already pay a form of a wealth tax
and i'm not a millionaire far from it as
my wife will tell you
many of you probably pay that same
wealth tax it's called the property tax
that's a tax on an asset you owned the
only difference between
that concept and ours is twofold first
we're saying that is all of your assets
cumulatively
that in excess are more than 50 million
dollars before it kicks in uh
so that is the two differences first is
that it's cumulative
we're looking at all the assets and then
second we're providing an exemption
worth
50 million dollars so look
i have and i've gotten this question
today as well about what will happen
next on this
i will tell you i have no doubt none
whatsoever
that this is an idea a concept that will
go very quickly
from impossible to inevitable because it
is fair
and it is right and it goes to the very
heart
of what this country stands for thank
you
good so we'll take questions how about
if we start with any questions around
the wealth text and then if you've got
other questions we'll stay for those
sure um first question senator warren do
you believe this wealth tax should go in
the second reconciliation bill and if so
when do you think that
look i'd be delighted to see us move
forward with the wealth tax
at any point uh it's something we need
in america and that's why we're out here
today we're putting it out so everyone
can see it
and start to talk about it it's got a
lot of details
in how it works it's got things like
what the uh
what the rate will be for uh uh
monitoring the income and uh
checking out each of the billionaires
that are subject to it and the ultra
millionaires
uh but we want to put it out there so
people can start to consider it
and put it in a package we need to move
forward on this
i asked that only because the covid bill
shows the struggle of getting
republican votes for president biden's
agenda what happens do you think broadly
to aspects of his agenda including taxes
that things keep getting bottled up with
60 votes
there are two answers to that the first
one is
every time the republicans want to talk
about cost
then we should be talking about revenue
and that's wealth tax
they want to complain about what things
cost we're putting forward
a way to pay this is a
way to make sure that we are being
physically responsible going forward
and the second is you raise the question
of the filibuster
look we can't give mitch mcconnell and
the republicans
a veto over the work that needs to be
done
in america america elected democrats
to come here and get things done and it
is our responsibility to do that
not to hand mitch mcconnell an automatic
no
on anything that he and his billionaire
friends don't like
if you want to add anything either one
of you step up brendan go ahead
i'll just add save real quickly um
look we had a we obviously had a debt
and deficit issue
before this um over the last year
we have spent from the cares act through
what we just voted for in the house
well past midnight the other night we've
been spending a lot of money
and by the way i voted for every single
one of those i absolutely support it
but i recognize that at some point we
are going to have to turn to revenues
well here is a fair way to do it
here is where as willie sutton once said
when asked why rob banks
here is where the money is this is a
hell of a lot better way to get revenue
than taxing middle class and poor people
in this country
okay yes you started these comments
talking about the inequality of the
pandemic why isn't this a part of the
bill uh right now uh in the covid
package
we're putting together emergency relief
which means
it's not about the revenue side it's
about where we need to spend money
and as the biden administration has made
clear
we need to spend money on getting the
vaccines out the door we need to spend
money
on making sure that people who need help
the most
are getting that help and we need to
spend money on getting our schools open
that's the thrust of covert relief now
what we need to turn to is build back
better we need to turn to infrastructure
child care pre-k college
we need to turn to the things that
create investment and opportunity going
forward
and to do that a wealth tax is the best
way to pay for it
yes some scholars have said there might
be constitutional issues
we have included in the package
multiple letters from scholars
who are confident that there are no
constitutional issues
here and really i'll just stop there
because there's not much more to say you
can kind of go into the
to the individual pieces and the
arguments
but we tax income in the united states
we tax estates
in the united states we're already
taxing property
in the united states the difference is
the congressman
identified is that this is a tax
that hits only the top one tenth
of one percent and you know we're
talking a lot about fairness
in our tax system the 99
in america are paying an average of
about
7.2 percent of their total wealth
in taxes that top one tenth of one
percent
they're paying about 3.2 percent
adding two cents in a wealth tax
means they're still getting a great deal
but it's time for them to pay a fair
share
and i am completely confident that
this is a constitutionally responsible
way to do it
i just wanted to add something in terms
of people paying
at a wealth tax now brendan mentioned
real estate but also when you die
your estate is valued and you have to
pay taxes at that point
so it's not like we don't already have
this we already are doing this
we just happen to be giving a lot of
people a big break
all along the way where they're
accumulating more and more wealth
which is again why these inheritances as
they're passed down
actually impact a smaller and smaller
group of people
largely white because that's where the
wealth was to start with you don't have
to pay any tax on it until you transfer
it
and so i don't think i mean i think that
there's a lot of reasons why
this stands up constitutionally actually
i should just add because
pramila makes the point that i just want
to make sure everyone sees it we do the
valuation now too
we do the valuation for all of the big
estates we just do it at death
but that happens there every year
somebody dies uh
and so we're doing those valuations what
we're saying
is you do the valuations every year and
of course once you've done them
they become much easier year over year
over year
once you've identified that somebody has
a rembrandt painting they better still
have a rembrandt next year or they
better have a whole lot of millions of
dollars
that they can account for when they sold
the rembrandt um
so this is already in our tax process
what's different about it is it truly
focuses on the richest people in this
nation
the people who could afford to pay a
fair share
understand their wealth will continue to
grow
you know the during the pandemic
they have increased the billionaires
have increased the trillionaires
the billionaires have increased their
wealth by 1.3 trillion dollars
but they've been growing their wealth
uh for years now at six percent
eight percent 10 12 they have their own
money managers their own people who
who who manage these great fortunes
a two cent wealth tax means they just
don't grow it quite as
fast but that two cents is an enormous
difference
for the rest of america it is an
opportunity for every child in america
to have universal pre-k an opportunity
for every child
to have child care paid for and every
parent and to raise the wages of every
child care worker
we can make a huge difference with this
wealth tax senator if you can expand
more on your calls to end the filibuster
it
doesn't have necessarily 51 votes yet do
you
anticipate that as time goes on and you
have other proposals from the biden
agenda that might be stymied
by the lack of having 60 votes do you
anticipate that more of your colleagues
will join you in calls to end the
filibuster because that seems to have
been a roadblock for democrats for some
time
so look um
the filibuster is something that gives
mitch mcconnell
a veto and that has to stop
we watched him use it during the obama
administration
and he is already using it now during
the biden
administration we weren't elected
to come here and be a debating society
that gives mitch mcconnell a veto on
every single piece of legislation that
is needed
to help american families i believe
that as we talk about the pieces that
we're trying to move forward
whether it's the minimum wage whether
it's protecting the vote
across america whether it's
anti-corruption
whether it's universal child care and
universal college for all of our kids
that more and more people will see what
mitch mcconnell is trying to do
more people will see it across the
nation and more people will see it
in the senate i believe we need to get
rid of the filibuster now
if i can follow up please of course do
you agree with
some of your house colleagues that the
vice president should overrule
the parliamentarian when it comes to the
inclusion of minimum wage
in the covert release package i agree
but
understand the only reason that we're in
this mess
is because of the filibuster if we would
get rid of the filibuster then we
wouldn't have to keep trying to
force the camel through the eye of a
needle instead
we would do what the majority of
americans want us to do
and in this particular case that's
raised the minimum wage do you think the
president should encourage
the vice president to take that action
then in the short term i think we should
get rid of the filibuster
yes i think this is a short-term
solution but the real solution is get
rid of the filibuster
and just to be clear just to be clear as
chair of the progressive caucus and
brendan as a member
we have said the same thing that there
are really two choices here because
we are in a place where we have to
deliver on the many promises we've made
passing hr one passing the john lewis
voting rights act passing a 15
minimum wage all of these things are
actually bipartisan across the country
and so we have two choices here we
either well i guess we have a third
which is to give mitch mcconnell the
override the veto power for
for everything that democrats have
promised and want to do
but the other is we can include it in
reconciliation
and overruling the parliamentarian is
not unprecedented
hubert humphrey did it in 1967 and 1969
rockefeller did it in 1975 but if we're
not going to do that
then the other path is the filibuster
and and elizabeth is right this is all
because
of the way the rules were set up and
frankly the filibuster was set up
to really strengthen the power of
southern segregationists
and and that is the history of the
filibuster so we should be very clear
that i believe the president biden wants
to do everything he can
to address racial in inequity in this
country and inequality
and if we are going to deliver on those
promises
we will have to reform the filibuster
yes and to follow up on that question
did the
parliamentarian's decision sort of give
you one issue that you can peg
um ending the filibuster to as opposed
to
maybe the abstract you know the entire
agenda
is there a strategy or conversations to
maybe just hang your company
i don't want a strategy uh
i want us to get rid of the filibuster
because it is too costly to america
the peace in front of us right now is
the minimum wage
but the piece that's coming up is the
voting rights act
and the piece after that is immigration
reform
and another piece is universal child
care
the the uh infrastructure package
is very different if the republicans get
a veto
at every turn through that process
so if we want to deliver on our promises
we got to be willing to get out there
and fight for it and that starts with
getting rid of the filibuster
brendan you want to yeah just said
something real quick because this has
been a pet peeve of mine for a long time
and i have the opportunity
um there's one advantage of having a
philadelphian up on this stage
this very issue was debated at the
constitutional convention in
philadelphia
they considered the idea if you read the
federalist papers in two different
um sightings hamilton and madison talk
about this
they considered the concept of a super
majority and they rejected it
so people who argue i was on a tv show
and a person brought this up oh well you
know you're going against the way it's
always been our founding fathers
nonsense that is complete garbage that
is bad history
the fact of the matter is our nation's
founders were quite smart they were not
perfect
but they were wise they considered the
super majority
requirement which is what the filibuster
is they considered a super majority
requirement in the upper chamber
and they rejected it and they rejected
it for exactly what we're seeing now
almost a quarter of a millennium later
going off of that though respectfully
you have two democratic
colleagues of your senator manchin and
senator cinema
who have also said that they don't
support ending the filibuster and
they've been against raising the minimum
wage in this provision to 15
an hour as well so you know are you
worried about pushing progressive
policies through
when you have opposition within your own
party and there's this division between
progressives and moderate look i i know
that everyone likes to talk about the
divisions within our party
but what brings us to washington as
democrats
is that we're trying to make this
government work for working people
i believe all of us are in favor of
raising the minimum wage
i believe all of us are in favor of
better support for our children
and more housing opportunities more
investment in
infrastructure now there are going to be
ways that we're going to have to
negotiate
with each other on those but the key
is that we are here to get things done
and the more that mitch mcconnell blocks
then
i believe the case gets stronger and
stronger for filibuster reform
just one more alrighty
do leader schumer and speaker pelosi
support the wealth tax but do they
support putting it on the floor for a
vote
you should ask them you're on the
leadership team
yeah yeah do you want me do you have any
i don't want to i don't want to speak
for them
but but i do want you know they know
about this and we have spoken
about this but you should i i shouldn't
speak for someone else
sure are the members here prepared to
vote against the stimulus that doesn't
have minimum wage are you making that
explicit correct go ahead what what we
have said
what we have said is we have to look at
the final package we have to look and
make sure
that it is not weakened in any way i'm
very proud of us in the house and
progressives were a key part of keeping
not only the 15 minimum wage in but also
the survival checks at the same
income thresholds that were originally
there in december
and so we need to see what's in the
final package but we have made it clear
that the minimum wage is a priority for
us and that keeping it
at the same level with the same items
that we passed in the house
is going to be very important for
progressives good wealth tax questions
sure we'll do a real quick wealthtrack a
real quick one you would mention
revenues that would be raised just to
make sure i understand do you believe
those revenues should go
toward uh reducing the debt or to fund
other priorities
i think it should go to fund other
priorities but the point is this is
three trillion dollars over the next 10
years
and yet it would affect only a hundred
thousand families
in america and and i just hope everybody
dials in on that for a second we talk
about
income inequality in this country and
this slope kind of looks like this
but it's wealth inequality where the
slope looks like this the difference
between the very tippy top
and the rest of america is enormous
and that very top is not paying a fair
share
they are paying less than half of their
wealth
in taxes unlike the 99
we're just asking them we're saying you
made it there
good for you but pitch in two cents
so that other kids in america have a
chance to build a future that's what
this
is about building a future good thank
you and i want to thank my two
colleagues for being here
it is terrific it's always terrific to
work with good people from the house
but i'm delighted to have someone from
ways and means uh
this is exciting uh and uh i'm excited
now to be in finance
uh over on the senate side and i'm
always delighted
to be here with congresswoman jaya paul
in this and the leader of the
progressive caucus so
thank you all for being here thank you
who did this there we go